welcome back Boris Johnson says he's
getting tough on law and order and
failing a wave of new policies including
more prison places and an extension of
stop and search powers with me is Kip
Malthouse the new Minister for policing
and crime a longtime colleague of the
new PM thank you very much so let's
start first of all perhaps you've seen
it Michael Heseltine Betty Boothroyd
they've written an op-ed in The Sunday
Times talking about Sir no deal brexit
being the most grotesque act of national
self-harm committed in peacetime by
British government it's a big accusation
particular coming from a toy owner of
your policy yeah I mean obviously
there's a lot of hyperbole being thrown
about as we approach the date of the
31st of October but in the end even
people like Lord Hesseltine great
figures from the past who have never
quite reconciled themselves the idea
that we're going to leave the European
Union are gonna have to focus on the
fact that that's what the British people
commanded us to do and that's what the
government is committing to do at the
end of October do you think we're ready
October 31st I think we will be ready
yes I mean obviously there's a huge
amount of work to be done between now
and then you know the cabinet committees
were meeting on a daily basis you know
Michael Gove is leading the charge he's
been in Northern Ireland recently told
them about preparations there the Prime
Minister has made it very clear that the
Treasury has to put money forward to
help with those preparations and also to
be ready to ameliorate it any impact
that may be well if we do leave with no
deal alongside that obviously profoundly
the government is trying to get a deal
and we want the Europeans to recognize
that a deal is in both of our interests
that they need to start talking to us
about what that might look like and
specifically on policing I mean let's
let's look there's there was a document
that was leaked to my colleague Sam
Coates not that long ago about the
consequences in the first day the first
fortnight the first month of an Oda
brexit and it's got some pretty stark
conclusions about what might well happen
actually we've got the document right
here and particularly in that middle
column security possible in the first
fortnight possible increased risk of
serious organised crime people smuggling
illegal migration and then look at the
far-right heightened policing resource
over the first month unsustainable
operational gaps continue to emerge this
is kind of scary stuff it's very yo I'm
not going to comment on leaked
government documents but it is it is
fair to say that the police like every
other part of the government
be prepared for No Deal and we need to
make sure that those forces across the
land are doing what they need to do to
make sure that they can continue to
function in the event of no deal now
there are lots of impacts if that comes
to pass that need to be thought about
and we are pretty clear that there are
workarounds for most of them to make
sure that we can be in as good a
position as we are now so you're ready
to provide more police officers for you
know when it talks about consumer panic
and increased risk of people smuggling
well I don't think these things are
necessarily going to come to pass but
it's certainly the case that these are
real risks though but the police are
need to be ready in all eventualities
for risk I mean you know policing is
about handling risk as you may remember
I spent four years as deputy mayor for
policing in London and one of the things
that time that taught me is that you
need to be ready for the unexpected and
so making sure that the police force in
its widest sense across the whole of the
country is ready for any eventuality
whether it's brexit related or otherwise
will be a key part of the strategy and
if talks in the deep Boris Johnson talks
about having more police officers and
20,000 extra officers yes the big
promise how much does that going to cost
so the first year we've scoped out looks
about 500 million we reckon about 1.1
billion over the whole period but what
the prime minister said quite clearly is
that 20,000 is the number we need to
focus on now I'm in conversation with
the wider policing family about the
practicalities and logistics of
delivering those 20,000 over the next 36
months and whatever costs fall out of
that obviously we'll have to have
discussions with the Treasury so it
could be even it could be even more than
1.1 billion well we'll see let's see
where we get to because there's lots of
other aspects to be looked at I mean one
of the pleasing things that the Prime
Minister is kicking off this weekend as
well is for us to realise that this is a
system that we're dealing with it's not
just about policing that we also have to
look at the criminal justice system the
prison system offender management the
courts the Crown Prosecution Service
that all of this fits together as a
system for managing crime and hopefully
pushing it downwards as far as we
possibly can and so he's making some
announcements today about you know more
funding going into the prison system
that will have more prison places to
provide for more violent offenders to
spend more time inside then tomorrow he
saw
a roundtable on violence specifically
with you know members of the criminal
justice system coming together with the
policing community to talk about what we
could do to drive violence down in the
country but have you have you worked out
presumably you have at this stage where
those extra police officers are actually
going to go I mean where they most need
it right now no so that's one of the
conversations that we'll be having with
police and not so noisy so the stage
looks like this so we're at about a
hundred and twenty three thousand police
officers at the moment there was a plan
already afoot from a billion pounds of
extra funding last year to recruit
another three and a half thousand across
the country we're now putting in place
to launch in September the next wave to
get the twenty thousand on top of that
over the next thirty six months between
then and now we have to have a
conversation about the deployment of
those police officers and critically
what they're going to be doing because
what the public want to see is a
restored sense of governance of the
public realm right alongside some of the
enhancements to stop and search so we're
putting in place today to deal with the
big rise in knife crime that we really
want to address assertively we do need
to address this general sense among the
public that they want more reassurance
from that police officers and do you
kind of concede that you know extra
police officers is is certainly a good
thing and many people within the police
and elsewhere will be relieved to see
that although first off it may not quite
even get us back to the peak in 2010 I
mean we're not we're not necessarily
even going to hit that peak pretty
austere attea are we what we need to get
the numbers back up because what we want
to do is both increase the capacity and
the effectiveness of the police now I've
got a 36-month job to get these 20,000
that's a big enough job on its own it'll
be the biggest expansion in policing
probably ever and so once we get to that
stage let's see where we are the
critical thing though is not so much to
focus on the number of police officers
but on the product on what are the crime
figures doing and you know we have seen
unfortunately over the last couple of
years an alarming rise for example in
serious youth violence which mirrors
arise we saw back in 2006 seven and then
in eight that we need to get on top of
an arrest and that will be the primary
focus you know we can get obsessed as we
obviously do in government on inputs but
really we need to focus on outputs and
what the public wants is to see a
reduction in crime generally but and
again police officers is one
but are you you know are you going to
have a place for them to actually work
out of I mean there are big concerns
about many police stations have been
shut down about 600 over the last few
years so are you going to start actually
buying them back you're going to start
building new police stations well we do
need to talk about logistics I mean when
we first announced the 20,000 police
officers there was some hilarity in the
media because I referred to one of the
restraints being access to lockers you
know police officers carry a lot of
equipment and so 20,000 lockers is a lot
of space pleasingly I've already had
contact some local government colleagues
counselors and others saying that they
would be happy to work with us looking
for the space that we need for police
officers and that certainly I think an
opportunity there for us to look across
the whole of the estate of the public
sector local government you know
certainly in some parts the country the
fire service and the police I was
already working together to see what we
can do to embed police officers as part
of that wider family and it speaks as I
say to a general systemic approach to
crime that we need to take account of
now you know we can't arrest our way
necessarily out of these problems we all
need to work together on the system
alongside as I say more assertive
enforcement you can't arrest your way
out but your boss Priti Patel talks
about people needing to fill terror
towards the police do you think that's a
fair assessment well we certainly want
criminals to be in fear of the police
detecting them and catching them and
putting them inside yes I mean you know
we know that the greatest deterrent to
crime is the perception of the
likelihood of getting caught and that's
psychologically what we need to increase
I mean one of the advantages for example
of section 60 stop and search which the
Home Secretary has announced she's
expanding powers of today is that it
speaks with kind of high-profile police
presence in a particular geography that
raises the perception of the likelihood
of detection of a knife and that means
that you're going to diminish the
likelihood that somebody is going to
carry one in the first place and
prevention is really what we're after
but there are also other concerns with
stop and search about potentially
increasing racial tension as well I mean
proportionally by far in a way the the
biggest proportion of people who are
stopped and searched are black young men
for the most part yeah look it the same
was true back in 2008 when we instituted
a big push against knife crime in London
and it's definitely the case that you
know we have to work
very closely with all communities across
the country to make sure that stop and
search is done in a sensitive and
professional way now things have changed
you know the vast majority of uniformed
officers now wear a body camera so the
interaction between them and the person
who's being searched can be filmed which
will lead to you know a
professionalization and in fact a better
reaction with the person's being
searched as well but you know in many
parts of the country there are people
stepping forward from all sorts of
communities particularly parents saying
they are so concerned about the welfare
of their young people that they
recognize that while stop and search is
controversial and can be assertive
you know it's necessary when you're
facing a crisis like this very quick
question because we're almost at the end
once the next election gonna be oh I
have absolutely no idea I hope it won't
be until the end of the the five year
term which is 2022 okay but who knows
okay you hope so okay well Kip Morehouse
we'll see whether there will indeed be
that election sooner or later